I feel like the Lee's gonna jump out
opening the box what's your real name
when people ask about the real name it's
almost like where characters are we're
in the States play or something nobody
real name I just told you does every
trans person transition fully every
trans person's full transition is
different you don't need to look like me
you don't need to look like you what are
some issues that have come up while
dating Oh Lord sweet baby Jesus we can
be here all day
because I don't date the conventional
type of person it makes it a little bit
more challenging sometimes I've always
dated sis men but recently a dative
trans guy and the sex is really really
good so um I'm excited am I still
straight if I want to [ __ ] you how rude
you are attracted to them because they
look female then I don't understand why
you would consider yourself gay how well
do you think that you pass a ha ha ha ha
I see beauty in all aspects if you are
passing or not passing when did you
decide to be trans now that's not how it
works kids none of this is a choice it's
a choice whether you're gonna act on it
or not and I thought am I gonna be happy
for myself or miserable for everyone
else
what happens if slash win you change
your mind what are we gonna be
transitioned off to get my titties
removed how do I ask someone their
preferred pronouns politely if I am
unclear that's a good question like a
human being
you ask them under direct clear question
what if they seem offended cuz if I was
at Starbucks and they said what's your
preferred pronoun I'd be like [ __ ]
can I get my latte what's the worst
thing assist person has ever said to you
God doesn't make mistakes they're right
I live a Purpose Driven Life during my
military experience like we're clearly
like I look masculine my military
documentation says I'm a mask
in person but like the records for the
military didn't say that I was masculine
so that military law says that they can
still call me female even though you
know you have a medical team and you
voted for this country that else's
people one thing what would it be the
murder rate of trans women especially
trans women of color is so high you
don't have to understand us you don't
have to understand every single gender
identity or trans experience in the
world you can respect us you need to
stop projecting on to other people what
you think is normal because it's not
normal it's common just me your your
support and your understanding and your
love and 1 million dollars each many 1
million in one because I don't want to
spend a dollar like oh my god I'm not a
millionaire anymore
[Music]